right let's make a start hello good
evening welcome everybody
uh to tonight's uh meeting of the
planning committee my name is danny
kendall i'll be chairing tonight's
meeting in accordance with the rules and
procedures as set out in the front of
your agendas before we get started i'm
just gonna run through a bit of
housekeeping for members of the public
if that's okay
uh just to start with um for members of
the public watching here in the room
tonight not at home um
just to make you aware that obviously
this is uh not a public meeting it's a
meeting that's being held in public um
if you haven't registered to speak
previously then you won't be permitted
to speak in this meeting tonight i'm
sure you all understand that and
obviously we want the meeting to
progress in a smooth and calm way
given that i've just talked about
register to speak i'm going to talk a
little bit about our covid rules if you
are registered to speak um please at the
right time come on up to the front we've
got some chairs and desks at the front
here
if you would when you sit down use the
hand sanitizer sanitize your hands and
then you can speak
after that when you finish speaking if
you just use the wipes that are in front
of you as well there are some little
anti-back wipes if you wipe down the
desk and the button for the speaker as
well when you leave that'd be much
appreciated hopefully we won't have to
put up with
this coved flummery for too much longer
but we will have to put up with it for
tonight
next then uh
phones if you could please make sure any
mobile phones turned silent that'd be
helpful
and finally on my housekeeping rules
just to let you know that tonight's
meeting of course is being filmed it's
going out live on youtube right now and
will be available for you to watch again
in the next few days should you wish to
do so
right okay i'll move to uh introducing
some of our officers on my right is uh
anne bank she's from committee services
on my left is catherine tebby she's our
legal expert tonight
then we have david jeffrey who is our
planning manager would you like to say
anything at this point thank you chair
yes my name is david jeffrey i'm the
planning manager for tonight's meeting
my role is to provide impartial advice
to clarify any planning issues that
arise and to assist members decision
taking i am bound by the royal town
planning institute's code of
professional conduct
planning committee members are not bound
by advice from officers or by their
recommendations
thank you thank you david
right okay then finally uh final last
but not least our officers uh alison
willis
sarah mcpherson and amy flute who will
be presenting applications for us
tonight right that's our introductions
out the way
so we move to item one apologies for
absence
gentlemen got apologies from councillors
richard adam
crump and eddon
thank you
okay a disclosure of interests from
members of the committee i'll kick this
one off that's all right regarding our
first application tonight which is item
four
um i've received a number of emails from
at least three or four members of the
public i
trust that i think everybody has here so
if we can take that as read as a
declaration of interest from everybody
on the committee that's excellent
fantastic uh any other declarations of
interest councillor curtis thank you yes
i'd like to declare interest in item
seven the bell shottery i will be
speaking on behalf of residents
objecting to this application thank you
and you will leave the committee for
that that's fantastic thank you any
others
right no further disclosures that's
great and uh the minutes uh that's item
three uh of the meetings held on the
27th of october and the 10th of november
are you content those we signed
thank you very much okay then
right before we jump straight in um i'm
just going to make a couple of changes
with your permission to the running
order of tonight's committee because
we've had a few changes
so uh item five
which was i will read the application
number it's twenty one slash zero one
four five zero slash f u l that one uh
has been um the p the parish council
with an award member withdrew their
objections uh therefore that application
has already been uh sent back and under
delegated authority to the officers so
that won't be heard tonight
and then the next application which is
item six
i just get the application reference on
that as well that's twenty one slash
zero zero seven two seven slash ful um
the reason for that application being
before committee was that uh a parish
council had objected uh they've not
however uh registered to speak and they
haven't actually changed their
recommendation and it's all on the
update sheet
so for that reason um i think we can
delegate that one back to offices as
well i will need a proposition on that
one councillor dixon to propose council
performance second that that application
be delegated back to offices all those
in favor please show
you're not a mess lovely so the i think
i'll read out the form of words so the
the committee resolves to delegate
application reference two one slash zero
zero seven two seven slash f u l right
those two are out of the way
back to the normal running order then
and we'll get back to item four on our
agendas which uh is sorry found on page
17 of the agenda
this is application reference 21
0 3 one
two six slash ful and his land known as
the lynch meadows warwick road stratford
uneven is for the change of use of the
land to form increased public area of
open area space to include various other
works i'm not gonna read everything else
out presenting officers allison willis
allison over to you
thank you mr chairman
so um this is an application for the
change of use of land to form an
increased area of public open space
and works to include
extension to the fisherman's car park
associated access improvements
pedestrian
cycle paths ponds earthworks riverbank
riverbank regrading
shelters and other structures platforms
boardwalks and planting
on a site on the approach to stratford
from the north east
the general location is shown by the
black god
this is the application site shown by
the red line
it runs along the flood plain
past the back of the leisure center the
crowne plaza hotel and the marina as far
as bridge foot
the southern section of the site is in
the conservation area which is marked by
the solid pink line
which is
this line here
if you can see my cursor
here is a recent aerial view of the site
showing the application site outlined in
red
it's open countryside with the river
running running along the eastern
boundary of the site
along here
so this slide shows the master plan
and the inset for the area around
fisherman's car park
the proposals for the site are
comprehensive but there are two overall
objectives
firstly to increase the levels of
accessibility for both cyclists and
pedestrians
and secondly
to retain enhance the site's existing
biodiversity along with establishing a
sound foundation for the ongoing
management of the site
as part of which is all part of working
towards achieving local nature reserve
status
revised plans have been received and the
proposals now no longer involve any
additional car parking at fisherman's
car park
however
there are still small extensions and
improvements to the existing car park
including permeable paving
in this area
if you can see my cursor
um
surfacing to the new toilet
new servicing in this area for a new
toilet block
space
here for a
mobile catering van
and seating and cycling stands in this
area
the main features of the overall
proposals are as follows
this however is not a exhaustive list
a number of different routes across the
site
linking it with the leisure center car
park in the town will be maintained and
created including
the existing tarmac path which runs down
the riverbank
will be improved and resurfaced and
widened for the section nearest the town
along here
a footpath cycle way leading
up up to the fisherman's car park
up through here
if you can see my cursor
um boardwalks bird hides dipping
platforms
there's a wild wood and willow trail
which is aimed at younger children
including willow structures sculptures
den building areas
there's a hardwood sleeper walkway
and a network of informal known grass
paths
there are a number of improvements to
the bridges
the existing bridge along the riverside
footpath is to be replaced with a three
metre wide timber bridge
and the steep concrete bridge
down here
is to be replaced with an 18 meter long
three and a half meter wide timber clad
steel single span bridge
parapets of the bridge in this area to
be repaired
and there's a hard hardwood beam bridge
to be installed across
one of the existing ditches
there are a number of improvements to
the landscape
including regrading of the banks up here
and we'll have a mix of reeds and open
water that's in this area
materials to be excavated from the
swales and re-beds will be deposited
onto the site to form two landscape
mounds at the rear of the leisure center
car park that's here and here
there are sculptural earthworks in this
area
designed as informal play features or a
venue for informal picnics
a large proportion of the site is to
remain undisturbed apart from targeted
ecological landscape maintenance
additional trees are to be planted in
the leisure centre car park
the existing route or vegetation
is to be cleared and areas are to be
sewn with wildflower grass mix
selective thinning is to be carried out
to increase the like light levels which
will improve the structure of the
plantation woodland
because woodland wild flowers are to be
introduced and marginal is established
on the banks of the swanery
native shrubs are to be planted on the
low mounds
up here
and new re-bed is to be established in
the elbow of the river bend it's in this
area here
so this slide shows some of the
structures proposed
so there's the toilet block which
includes a disabled toilet
some of the boardwalks
some of the replacement bridges
and this is the bird hide
so for those of you not familiar with
the site of the next few slides i'm just
going to fly through just to give you a
flavor of what the site is currently
like
so that's the entrance of the existing
car park fisherman's car park
looking across the river from the
fisherman's car park
as another angle
as the house is on the opposite bank
um that's one of the tracks leading
north out of the car park that's the
existing tarmac path as it leads goes
back towards stratford
that's one of the open areas which has
already been sewn with wildflower seeds
that's the riverbank walk
that's one of the bridges that's going
to be replaced
um
that's part of the black platform that's
going to be thinned that's a bit further
towards the town
this is the existing concrete bridge
which is quite steep and gets quite
slippery in the winter so that's going
to be
replaced with a 18 meter span
steel in the timber cloud bridge which
will be much gentler gradient
and that's
one of the existing tracks as it uh as
it's leading north
that's that's the end of the
presentation
thank you um
mr chairman there are a number of
updates as per the update sheet
in addition i have one further verbal
update that the town council have
withdrawn their objection and have
submitted a no representation in its
place
um so to the recommendation um following
the removal of the
local flood authorities objection
officers are now
um recommend that the application be
granted subject to the conditions and
notes contained within the agenda
and the additional condition for an
additional
bollard as mentioned in the update sheet
the detailed wording and numbering of
which is to be is granted to officers
thank you
that's great thank you arson
right we'll go to our first speakers on
this um we've got uh liz willits
anderson liz willits you there yes if
you'd come up i know you got deb debs
captain are you here just for questions
if needed that's fantastic okay
if you want to yeah there's no reason
you shouldn't
that's okay
okay
so
you of course can take your masks off
now you've sat there that's absolutely
fine if you want to
i know the feeling
it's okay
so you have three minutes between you
obviously i think um liz you're going to
be going first time so any questions
later on um if you'd remain seated for
any questions the committee may have at
the end that'll be fantastic and i'll
give you a warning at the last 30
seconds of your time so you've you know
to wrap up is that all right
in that case whenever you're ready uh
pres
oh that's the one yet give that a press
is the red light come on i can't see
from here lovely over to you thank you
okay
well good evening i'm here to voice
objections to this plan
firstly due processes have not been
followed it lacks clarity about planning
issues and permitted development it
lacks detail regarding things like other
structures earthworks etc and the plans
are
confusing it contains out-of-date
information still on the application
form for for example about the car park
it contravenes the neighborhood plan and
the core strategy
it includes inaccurate information about
the landfill
lots of new information has been added
without extending the consultation
period
secondly there are objections to the
proposals because the plans describe a
recreational park not an lnr as promised
which should be a condition of the
planning permission where protection of
wildlife and natural habitats is
paramount
excessive intrusive recreational
facilities and other man-made features
are incompatible with the preservation
and conservation aims of an lnr
the area already meets the criteria for
an lnr without intervention except for
good management
hump and bump cycle tracks and
children's activities are much better
suited to the wreck
there were a hundred plus objectors and
there were five supporters but they're
all actually saying the same thing
create an lnr but without too much human
intrusion and consider the landfill
it's known to contain hazardous
materials not just chemical contaminants
but absolutely tons of broken glass
and
other detritus batteries and so on the
potential for linkage between
the um human receptors and the hazardous
hazardous materials and the animal and
plant receptors will increase if the cap
of the landfill is breached and if spoil
gets moved around the site
to use contaminated excavated spoil for
mounds picnic areas earthworks and so on
is contrary to british standard
en14899 2005
and a condition should require minimal
intrusion into the contaminated land as
well as off-site disposal of excavated
waste
a discovery strategy is a risky strategy
that could result in huge remediation
costs
the most pragmatic safest cheapest
option is leave well alone don't disturb
the landfill
30 seconds thank you it's poor value for
money it's not creating any jobs or
supporting businesses but it could be a
win-win situation prioritizing wildlife
and biodiversity
and creating educational and
volunteering opportunities and
supporting local businesses if we had an
l r in the north and a family fund park
on the wreck it doubles the offer for
both residents and visitors and kate
would cater for all ages and abilities
if there's a visitor center and a toilet
block on the leisure center car park
work could start immediately without
interfering with plant and animal life
cycles or habitat
now that's going to have my three-minute
presentation okay thank you and i'm
there if i'd let you stop at that point
because we have elapsed uh on the time
if that's okay but we'll open it up to
questions from the committee now if
that's okay do we have any questions
please anyone counselor curtis thank you
thank you liz um
two questions if i may um you mentioned
in your presentation
that there is inaccurate information
about the landfill in the report i
wonder if you could
perhaps give some examples of that and
um intrigue that i can actually see the
your train of material um
could you perhaps
it might be interesting for the
committee to know the depth under the
topsoil how how far that like that
material lies thank you thank you
thank you shall i deal with the first
one first
um
yes the the inaccurate information about
the landfill site
in the um in the associated documents in
um the planning application it refers to
the landfill site was licensed to accept
inert waste now
pre-1974 and the control of pollution
act local authorities weren't required
to keep records about what was going
into landfill and as far as i can find
out from the environment agency or any
other research
licenses were not granted to local
authorities because they didn't need
that level of regulation
inert waste refers usually to things
like garden soil and sand and so on
now i followed that up i tried to find
out
more about the so-called license
and i didn't receive a reply until
monday afternoon too late to actually
put it in a presentation
or anything but i've been told by the
environmental health
team at stratford district council
that the tip received four categories of
waste inert
industrial commercial and household
now that
to me doesn't mean that the industrial
and commercial waste were necessarily
inert it received inert waste presumably
the stuff as i've mentioned like sand
and soil but we do know that from the
various businesses that were operating
in stratford in the period that the tip
was operating from 1950 to 1971
there's a whole list of
businesses that would have been tipping
quite noxious things into the tip
because they were allowed to this isn't
a blame thing it's not it's no blame um
on the council which was probably the
borough council then not the district
council but
they would they were not doing anything
they shouldn't and nor were the
companies necessarily
um but we do know that a lot of horrible
stuff has gone into the tip
but it's not just the chemicals just
gonna come in there if that's i think
you'd probably explain the question did
you have a follow-up um
no well that was it so so
i understand i think from that that
there is
perhaps insufficient detail about the
i think we've had a lot of information i
think maybe council capital there's one
for coming back later as well
my other question if i make sure was
just um
yes
i think i think that's probably a
question for uh clarification later if
that's okay because it sounds like a bit
of a skilled in-depth question uh any
other points or questions from the uh
committee
none
in that case ladies thank you very much
for your time this evening if you'd wipe
things down for me that'd be fantastic
thank you very much
all right then i think um if we prepare
our next speaker please got liz
nicholson speaking as the agent for the
applicant please i noticed we've got
also uh nick stegel and uh mark stefan i
think you chaps are here for questions
as well are you am i right okay
is that how we're good yes that's
fantastic thank you
you've done the introductions for me so
um just to be clear i'm liz nicholson
the planning consultant advising on the
project and um we've got mark steffen
from design with nature and nick stegel
who's middle march environmental so
that's why these guys are here
if i could just jump in just so i'll
make sure i've got a fair you've got
three minutes yes stacy did pretty quick
that's okay
we we know obviously there's been an
awful lot of public interest in this
application
but the application is just about two
fundamental principles really
it's about the ecological and
biodiversity enhancement and future
management and maintenance this land and
it's also about improving access for
everybody into what's a beautiful part
of our town
and that's about getting you know the
people with the prams and the push
chairs it's the people with the walking
sticks and the wheelchairs
and everybody in between it's about
enabling them as you saw in the
photographs that were put up is enabling
them to use
existing pathways and some new ones so
that they can enjoy this area
i know there's nobody on this committee
that would disagree with those
fundamental principles so this is about
the details isn't it it's about the
details of the proposals
you all know that planning decisions
have to be based on evidence
you've got an application before you
where there's no technical objections
from your statutory council teas
there's now no objections from the
county council ecologist or from the
environment agency or from the county
council as lead local flood authority
and there's no objections from your
environmental health officer either
nick and mark are here because they know
all the details of the proposals
this is your opportunity to ask us
anything that you want to know that
would reassure you that the details of
the scheme are delivering those
fundamental principles that i'm sure we
all agree are the right ones
thank you
thank you
okay uh members of committee any
questions
yes council jennings
you mentioned about the maintenance plan
and could you tell us a bit more about
it and how long is it for
the um management plan once we um look
at the credits will be for 30 years
minimum
okay
any further questions please
no all right
getting off easily thank you very much
everybody if you'd again sorry to get
you to do all this if you'd wipe things
down that'd be fantastic thank you
and we'll pause for a second
okay we go to our ward member councillor
jefferson then if you'd like to come up
welcome counselor
we've all done that
right
how embarrassing
um
i support this uh planning application
i think it transforms the area into
something that will be attractive to
more people
indeed if one actually looks at the
principal design characteristics
which have already been outlined but
it's worth actually
refreshing them
to increase levels of accessibility for
cyclists and pedestrians
to retain and enhance the site's
existing biodiversity
along with establishing a sound
foundation for the ongoing management of
the site
as part of working towards achieving
of lnr status so i mean that's pretty
clear and those are really good
objectives
and if you look on page 25
uh the proposals offer significant
biodiversity enhancement with the
proposed planting and ponds
so in other words this really does
achieve some very clear objectives and
improvements
if one actually again
looks at the biodiversity impacts and on
page 29 the natural environment
the lynch meadows are designated as a
local wildlife site but without active
ecological management this area has
declined in ecological value and the key
driver of the current proposals is to
restore the ecological value of the land
i think that's pretty clear how much of
an improvement this will be
finally i just want to uh
reprise the conclusions of the planning
officer
uh
this satisf uh sorry in the conclusions
it's got a significant positive impact
with regards to environmental objective
of enhancing the site's existing bio
biodiversity
it establishes a sound foundation
for the ongoing management of the site
and it increases levels of accessibility
those are all incredibly worthwhile
outcomes for this site
and finally i would say that as there
are no outstanding objections from any
of the statutory councils
and would struggle to see any valid
planning reasons for rejecting this
application
and as i've outlined there are very many
good reasons for accepting it thank you
chair thank you uh do you have any
questions for the ward member
not at all
council jefferson get away lightly thank
you very much for your time as well all
right while you're wiping things down
let's move to points of clarification
then does anybody have any questions
we'll start with councillor dixon then
i'll run down the side as well
thank you
alison on page 28 land com plan
contamination
the north western half of the site is
recorded as being part of the historical
landfill looking at the plan do you know
the extent how far as it were did it go
right to the very
northern part of that site in which case
how far south did it come because
obviously the report here
refers and our first uh witnesses death
debs compton basically was referred to
this disturbance of that land and i'm
just wondering how much of that land is
uh potentially available for disturbance
okay let's go back to the master plan
uh it's primarily um
this this area around here less this
side
yes
yes i believe so
the
you mentioned mounds as well as part of
the sort of the land
i suppose
re-landscaping is that part and parcel
of that same area
is that
is that the landfill area
uh yes that that's deposited
it's not excavated not excavation it's
on top of
right so the only excavation is
potentially the car park
no extension right okay so there's no
reason for that to be disturbed
okay thank you and just for further
clarification so there'll be no
disturbance to the landfill whatsoever
um
very minimal but anything that's going
to change can we put on top of effect
to
recreate the re-bed in the elbow here
and some of the ditches will be
um clear that out
right
and then they'll be replaced with new
material on top
okay
all right sorry remove completely so
that's something that the environmental
agency considered very carefully
because they came to the conclusion that
there was no intrusive thank you
total clarity that's okay thank you for
that any uh yes we've got council mills
you've got a question
thanks mr chairman um alison you
mentioned the improvement of the
footpath are they um
what material has been used for that is
it
because you mentioned permiable well
this this area here is colored
in some places it's uh resin-bound
gravel
uh in some places it's just moan
it's a mixture oh is it so but the
tarmac path that's around the edge of
the river yeah
is that going to be widened then
around
it's being widened to three meters wide
okay um
and if i'm mr chairman um
that the hide the bird hide
is that going to be do we know it's
going to be locked in the evening
because i'm just worried about
people using it i'm sorry um
actually i don't know no okay
okay maybe
they may or may not be i mean no
i can take that away yeah if you would
play you said could anyway people could
be using in the evening couldn't they um
the other
activities
okay yeah both they're very quiet could
i ask you to bring it back
i'm struggling over here sorry oh sorry
mr chairman i shall speak louder then
and the psychopath pedestrian that's all
one isn't it is that uh are they do they
clash at all
um there's like this psychopath
is going
uh up through the middle here up to the
fisherman's car park here
but there are other routes there's like
there's a boardwalk room right
uh the existing tarmac path down the
edge
and there's um
kind of there's different trails it's
quite a network of different
parts so so the pedestrians and the
cyclists don't normally clash you don't
get run over by
cyclists who are pedestrians or don't we
know that
no accidents or anything like that no
okay all right
okay thank you very much
okay uh councillor curtis
okay um thank you
i'm just
just a couple of points really i'm
slightly confused over
whether there is an extension to the car
park or not because i think in your
presentation
you said there was going to be a small
extension to the car park
not for car parking spaces
the
the technically is an extension because
there's a bit of remodeling around the
access and entrance way into the car
park like the gates are being moved
barry is being moved back but also
there's a an additional area
can you see
here
that's a new
area of hard standing
which is for the catering van and the
toilets so
that technically is an extension of
may ground
and my other quick question i don't know
if you can answer this or not but um
i'm just wondering what percentage of
the existing
wild spacer wanted better term will
remain intact without any
footpaths cycle ways or other intrusion
well there's two areas which the county
ecologists have requested that
residents are excluded from in
bird breeding times so there's a walkway
with gates either end so that will be
that will be an exclusion at different
times of the year um
but
uh i'm not i'm not sure there's any
permanent um
permanent
12 months of a year areas excluded
because that's what the question was
it was really to try and understand how
much of the existing wild area
will remain undisturbed by cyclists
pedestrians other members of the public
walking through but we don't quite seem
to have that answer i don't think
uh i'm not sure i know that in
percentage terms i can see it
graphically but i don't know how to
translate that into a percentage
okay
uh council fleming
thank you chair um
as a member of the climate change panel
on the council i'm on about to ask um
biodiversity and whatever are we gonna
be neutral
with this or are we going to have a
positive effect on
on climate change as far as the site's
concerned and the biodiversity
i mean i see the ecology has no great
issues but and when you've been
considering the plans have you thought
about how it's going to affect the
biodiversity that's ready on that area
and
and are we going to be in a neutral
situation when it comes to climate
change effects if you like
so part of the application submission
there was a biodiversity impact
assessment um calculation done which is
essentially a score that's given to
the increase in the biodiversity value
of the site and actually it has a very
healthy increase uh positive score
okay
oh
yes council foreman thank you um
it says on page 29 there is an intention
to achieve a local nature reserve
designation for this site i take it the
management company the people are going
to manage it will be going on to try and
achieve that if you've got any idea how
long they think that's going to take
um further details of that have been
will be secured by condition but it's
something that needs to be worked on i
think so i mean
the
lnr status has different facets so it's
not only the biodiversity a big
important part of it is
both education and accessibility so
um all those all those three things i
think need need to be worked on to
justify l status okay thank you
and i think probably the last question
counselor curtis
sorry chair thank you very much um yes
it was
it was following on from my question
about the
car park non-extension if you like i'm
gonna notice on page 31
and the report does say that one of the
benefits from the scheme
will be a reduction of traffic onto the
bridge foot rotary and town centre
and i just wonder if there's no
extension to the car park
how there is a benefit to reducing the
traffic around the gyratory
um by having toilets and catering
facilities in their existing in the
fisherman's car park and cycling cycle
stands it enables people to to park
there instead of parking in the town
so essentially by virtue of making it a
more attractive place to park yes yeah
okay
um right oh yes couch henshaw seraphin
one more question thank you chair um
just one little question the loss of
three trees on the fisherman's carpet
are they going to be replanted with new
trees somewhere
the compensator
um two trees are being removed in the
access to improve the access because the
access on from warwick road is quite
dangerous at the moment
um
so
there's an extensive program of planting
trees all over the site so yes thank you
right okay
finish with points of clarification
should we go to the debate
who here would like counselor dixon
straight in filed by council jennings
i'll put a list together thank you
chairman um
i must admit it was interesting that uh
prior to coming this evening i'd
highlighted a paragraph on page 29.
um our ward member
read it out to the committee already and
certainly uh the the lynch meadows are
designated as a local wildlife site
but without active ecological management
this area has declined in value and a
key driver of the current proposals is
to restore this value of the land
we've heard this evening uh from dez
hampton obviously of fears concerning uh
the fact that
there could be disturbance of a of a tip
um
obviously our papers before us
don't indicate that there is any dangers
or are any dangers essentially um and
uh mr campton mentioned the fact that uh
in her words uh we know that there are
inert waste and dangerous
aspects to to the infill and that was
based upon i think an assumption
regarding the businesses and the
commercial activities which were in
stratford at the time
but i don't think we have any evidence
that anything
un inappropriate was deposited in that
tip we certainly don't have it before us
so on the basis that i can see no reason
not to approve it i will actually
propose that we grant recommendation in
accordance with the office's
recommendation chairman
thank you councillor dixon um uh i'll
pause off i think just a point of
clarification i think it was uh actually
uh liz willits who was mentioning
there's nothing but there we go don't
worry the name is possibly the other way
around which way you must take came in
uh thank you we have that proposed then
um we now go to council jennings
okay i like the the encouraging
of
this project
um
i see all the benefits of it
i think it encourages people to use the
car park it's going to create green
routes into
into town
it's going to reduce congestion and it's
going to improve air quality
um
pandemic i think has changed people's
attitudes to green space
um and introduced a lot of people who
otherwise wouldn't have gone into the
countryside to actually go into the
countryside or look at nature
um
and it just encourages a whole whole new
demographic to go into this area which
is for for everyone not just for the few
um
but to me the key issue here is the
disabled access um
i know i spent most of the weekend
reading through all the comments
um and seeing see what sort of
what sort of things people have put
forward
and uh i was reading i made two notes
um
one from ed terry of
heart of england mencap who said i want
to ensure that people with a learning
disability or anyone with additional
needs who lives in stratford have the
same access to its great parks and open
spaces as everyone else
this scheme will provide organizations
like heart of england mencap who support
people in the town with a learning
disability or with mobility issues to
enjoy the great outdoors and provide a
foundation to build back their lives off
over the past 15 months with covid
and then there's another one which was
caroline smith of inclusivity who said
the improvements open up natural areas
which were previously inaccessible
enhancing the opportunities for arguably
those in the most need to satisfy to
safely access a beautiful natural
setting the provision of the accessible
toilets in the lynch meadows is a game
changer for so many people i think the i
think it's a very very important factor
there
um there have been absolutely no
statutory objections to this
um i'm very happy to second the
uh recommendation that we go with the
officer
and uh recommend grant
thank you council jennings uh councillor
mills
yes thanks mr chairman actually uh
council jennings has probably said
a lot of eyes going to say it's i think
it's um
to me it's a lot of work and details
gone into this
um
i think it's going to be an improvement
um and i can if i can i can
third the and support the
recommendations so yes i'm happy to
support
you thank you councilman of course not
officially but thank you um anybody else
want to speak in the debate yes council
curtis
thank you um
i
there has been a great deal of work has
gone into this but
um
just picking up the point of the the the
landfill it's not just inert material
there have been
um you know there is evidence of a great
deal of very risky um stuff having been
dumped on the site and we're not
actually entirely sure what has been
done there so i think we do really have
to consider that very carefully um i was
just picking up i don't want to bang on
about the car parking too much but um
the the car park is already pretty much
used to capacity
it's my understanding
so i'm not quite sure
how
making it
more attractive to park there given that
the car park isn't actually going to
increase in size is actually going to
see this benefit of reducing traffic
onto the bridge foot and rotary town and
town centre that to me that just doesn't
stack up because it's already full to
capacity
um
just as a point of detail
i um the catering block in the toilet
block
i'd like to ask just why that can't be
cited adjacent to the car park to mark
to my mind if there's going to be hard
cover it's better to have it in one
place rather than on two sort of
separate sites
and i'm still
concerned that um
the
the i agree absolutely with councillor
jennings and councilman mills that
we should be providing as much
access for people who consider
themselves to be say be disabled as
possible i absolutely agree with that
aim
i'm just still concerned that there this
perhaps is creating the the balance
between the area that is retained solely
for nature
is is out of balance um in this present
proposal
thank you thank you
anybody else want to speak in the debate
i'll very briefly add my thoughts then i
think i'm in favor of this and everybody
who's spoken in favor of this broadly
reflects my views so i don't think i'll
go any further but i do support this
application as well
right we'll go to the vote then
if everyone's happy it's been proposed
and seconded that we grant this
application
all those in favor please show
one two three
four five
six chairman thank you all those against
abstentions
2
2k
therefore the planning committee
resolves to uh grant application
reference 20 somewhat 21
0 3 1 2 6
f u l uh we'll move to our next
application our final application which
is item seven uh i might give the
pause for 30 seconds to the room maybe
if people want to leave they can
and also let our planning office switch
around as well 30 seconds then
okay
we're just taking a brief pause while
some people come in because they have to
stay in the reception sorry about that
sorry you had to stay outside apologies
for that so all right i'll just give you
a few moments
okay i think we're all here again let's
uh let's proceed so this is item 7 on 57
page 57 that is application reference 21
006 8 7
ful and this is for the bell in in
shotery and it's for the erection of a
single story detached pergola railings
and fixed seating presenting officer amy
flute amy over to you
thank you chairman i'll just share the
screen
there we go
thank you chairman
the application site is denoted by the
black dot the site is within shotery and
stratford ponavan's identified buildup
area boundary the application site edged
red is an existing pub known as the
balin it is centrally located within
chattery with a one-way system around
its perimeter the site is within the
conservation area listed buildings are
coloured red on the plan the nearest
being to the south of the site
planning permission is sought for
external alterations to the garden area
the proposed hard standing
and
railings around the perimeter of the um
southern frontage are considered
permitted development the tables and
chairs which are shown do not require
planning permission the proposed pergola
and fixed seating
require planning permission and are the
subject of this application
the pergola will be sited to the south
of the existing pub and will be
grey-painted timber with tin with a
tinted glass roof
the fixed seating is to be to the north
of the existing wall and railings it
will be of a timber construction
this image shows the bow looking in a
north-westerly direction historically
there have been structures in the garden
area roughly in the area where my cursor
is now
this image is looking east towards the
pub's existing garden
and finally this image is looking in a
northerly direction towards the pub and
its garden
this conifer which is to the right is to
be removed
chairman it is not considered that the
proposal will result in unacceptable
harm to the landscape neighbouring
amenity or highway the public benefits
of this scheme are considered to
outweigh the harm to heritage assets
chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed within
the committee report please note that
there are some updates to the report on
the update sheet including the removal
of some of the suggested conditions
thank you chairman thank you amy
okay good after speaker uh mr mark is it
rayleigh mr rayleigh riley sorry i think
okay
thank you come on up
right i don't know you probably weren't
here for this so we do have to ask you
to sanitize your hands and
before you and then we'll ask you to
wipe down the table afterwards apologies
for that
so essentially you have three minutes to
speak if you remain seated for any
questions at the end that'd be fantastic
and if i'll and what i'll do is i'll
give you a 30 second warning towards the
end of your time
is that all right
that's good
all right
please do take a seat you don't need to
stand it's okay make yourself
comfortable
all right
that's the one in the middle
over to you okay
um
so mark riley representing shottery
residents
the first thing to say is that we all
want a thriving local
pub which makes money and which it does
the context is that as amy's already
mentioned that this is in a conservation
area
it's a walking route directly to anne
hathaway's
cottage
there were 39 objections in total some
of them were replicated but 39 in total
and three no objections
one of the main concerns for the
residents is the pedestrian safety
we feel that it will be compromised by
actually having borders put around
the planning
office has justified this with what they
call a runoff pavement area
pedestrians actually need to use this as
well as the grass areas you'll see on
slides
two and three where you've got children
having to jump out of the way of coaches
onto the grass area if there is a hard
border they will not be able to do that
the highways seem to be ignoring this
and we believe that
you know it's it's negligent and this
really should not get passed on grounds
of public safety
this is a conservation area and there
was an email from the previous officer
david millenship
which did recommend for a refusal
it's been withdrawn i believe from the
application
the conservation
team were not supportive and this was in
david milne ship's words
because of the heritage and visual
impact grounds
you know a small conifer that we're
seeing there on the right hand screen
has got a five foot girth and we think
any green area in the middle of a
village setting
should not be removed it also has quite
a big
sound and visual impact buffer on many
of the properties there of which one is
mine and many other residents there as
well
um parking
with at the moment they've got currently
45 external seats and the plan is to
increase it to 97. that's 110 increase
which will add 10 to 12 extra cars
the parking is difficult there and if
you're gonna have an extra 12 cars we
don't know where they're gonna go it was
suggested that they could go to cottage
lane but we've spoken to the head of
estates mark ratcliffe from the
shakespeare birth trust and he hasn't
been approached by his sons
uh or by green king
um so his concerns are that it isn't
monitored
at a weekend or after four o'clock
just to sum up um
it's in a village green setting
conservation do not support
we really suggest there should be no
removal of the trees the noise and light
pollution will increase
we believe this will seriously
compromise public safety and to ignore
this as a neglect
we believe we've all got a duty of care
for all users of shotery village
thank you
okay any questions please
from the committee
yes councillor mills
thank you thank you good evening i can
see the
the coaches uh putting up onto the path
there just
does this happen
often oh it happens every day
um
probably if i was being
estimating 30 to 40 times because you've
got three schools that it feeds
obviously shotery grammar school you've
got the primary school
um
and and you've also got um coaches and
lorries coming past there and to
navigate that corner the picture that's
up there at the moment they have to come
down hathaway lane and they have to go
across the second
lane so onto the opposite side to
navigate that corner
where that coach is at the moment if
they've got a hard border there they're
gonna be forced over
to against the residents cars
or or the actual houses and um
you know cars get hit regularly my my
both of my cars have been hit i've only
lived there for three years there was a
couple of pictures up there earlier on
and the neighbors has just recently been
hit as well
thank you
um and
do many people use that because it's
it's an inner um footpath isn't it
the picture you can see if you just go
back one please
the picture there
uh just forward one
could you just
what we're looking for that one there
thank you that one there as you'll see
um it's very narrow there push chairs
uh find it very difficult to navigate
that you can see there's just a little
cellar entrance there which is actually
micellar entrance
anybody with mobility issues who have
any um
frames to use find it difficult so
they're forced onto the other side and
then obviously they've got to jump out
of the way of any vehicles coming up
onto
this pavement area
i think that's the main point i think is
that
from a health and safety point of view
that's been
the highways have been neglecting saying
this is fine it's of purpose for
vehicles which it is but it's got to be
of purpose for pedestrians as well who
use it every day
thank you very much thank you
there are no further questions in that
case mr riley thank you very much for
your time if you could just get one of
those little hand wipes and wipe down
the desk for me and the microphone
button would be fantastic
thank you
thank you um okay we'll go to our next
speaker uh that's the agent helen bins
please
welcome
the same rules apply you have three
minutes if you remain seated for any
questions
whenever you're ready over to you
i'm here on behalf of the applicant
rinking brewing and retail in limited
and i act as their planning consultant
as i'm sure you're aware the kovid
pandemic has placed the hospitality
sector under extreme pressure and my
client is no exception
it is green king's experience from
across the country that establishments
that have a good quality outdoor space
and good quality covered seated areas
are much more financially stable than
those that don't and thus are more
likely to survive
it is also our experience that many
people still have a clear preference to
sit outdoors where possible
rinking believe that the current
direction of travel of the pandemic is
only going to reinforce this trend over
the coming months
the works for which planning permission
has sought form part of a wider garden
improvement scheme at the site and
general enhancements to improve the
attractiveness of the existing beer
garden
this includes the grassed area at the
front of the site which forms part of
the pub cartilage and can lawfully be
used for external seating and eating and
drinking
the majority of the improvement works do
not require planning permission as is
excellent in the office's report the
only works that do require planning
permission are the timber pergula and
the fixed seating
timber pergola replaces a previous
structure which was removed pre-covered
the structure provides an essential area
of covered outdoor seating that will
help the premises to continue to trade
viably the structure is of a good and
appropriate design and constructed of
high quality materials that are
appropriate to the conservation area
the scheme also involves the provision
of some fixed timber seating which by
virtue of not being loose requires
planning permission the seating is also
of good quality and is constructed of
appropriate materials and is appropriate
to the conservation area
it is proposed that new 900 millimeter
railings are provided around the
boundary of the site setting from the
back edge of the highway it is further
proposed that the area between the
highway and the railings be planted with
a lavender border
railings were not originally proposed
but were introduced to address criticism
from local residents that the beer
garden was unsafe without a physical
barrier to its edge however following
the introduction of the railings and
planting criticisms have now been made
that there is no area for pedestrians to
step out of the path of buses overrun in
the highway
i would draw members attention to two
points on this matter
firstly neither the planting nor the
railings actually require planning
permission and secondly highways have
advised that the area between the
highway and the site is not a pavement
but a runoff area for buses and
therefore should not be used by
pedestrians
i sympathize greatly with residents
concerns about pedestrian safety and i
can appreciate why they have raised the
comments and concerns they have however
the fact of the matter is that residents
objections don't actually relate to the
work 30 seconds but rather the historic
issues of buses overrunning what
residents consider to be the pavement
this is clearly not a mass for the
planning application and there are no
grounds in my view for planning
permission to be reviews for the scheme
on this basis
i trust therefore that you will feel
able to support the applicant and grant
planning permission for this development
which i also think will represent an
enhancement to the premises and
conservation every once is complete
thank you
thank you perfect timing any questions
please from the committee
yeah council hench the sarasota thank
you you say this um area pavement is not
a public pavement out to the front
okay
those those comments have come and i'm
sure amy can verify those comments have
come from the highway authority
themselves who've raised no objection
who has specifically said that that area
is not formal pavement it's a runoff
area now i i can't you know say either
way and obviously the residents have
commented that it is used by pedestrians
i can only go on what the highway i
think we've advised us okay thank you
i'm just going to ask a question
i'm mulling over in my head um you say
you added the railings and the hedging
at the request of residents not not at
the request of residence so original
there was an original scheme that went
in that had no railings in it at all
and
a number of comments um from residents
voiced concern about the idea that you
would have
an expanded seating area in that area
that potentially i guess she could have
small children and that actually because
of this issue with um buses potentially
over running um i'm not going to
describe it as pavement but overrun in
this area that um that was a risk that
children could basically run into the
path of a vehicle so the railings were
added to try and address that criticism
but in adding those railings we've now
come in for criticism that actually
there's no space for pedestrians to jump
out of the way so we're kind of damned
if we do window with damned if we don't
my next question again you probably
don't want to stop me at this point but
have you reconsidered your position on
those railings since hearing what we've
had tonight
i know what you've said
have you thought about that we we very
deliberately set the railings in from
the back edge of
the area in question and we've planted
that with them a lavender border so that
it does give a little bit of flexibility
so the railings aren't going to sit
right on the back edge of
the pavement or the area whatever you
want to to describe it as but um
the fact remains those railings do not
require planning permission in any event
yeah i am fully aware of that don't
worry it's okay
okay
right
there are further questions thank you
very much for your time as well
thank you for wiping that down
we can move to our ward member
councillor curtis
so can you quiet that down after you've
used it it's all right let's just give
it a good wipe there you go lovely
right
council curtis you have five minutes you
don't please don't you have to use all
of them but it's over to you thank you
thank you members of the committee and i
will be as brief as possible
as you've heard residents have raised a
number of concerns regarding this
application and whilst we're mindful of
the need to encourage local business as
outlined by the agent we also have a
duty of care to our residents and to
consider cautiously any negative impact
on our valuable conservation areas
duty of care and pedestrian safety
as clearly shown in the slides the
garden area of the bell pub currently
offers a safe refuse refuge for
pedestrians when loras and coaches use
this so-called overrun to negotiate this
bend
as has been pointed out this is not an
occasional nor infrequent occurrence and
i myself have frequently had to use this
area to avoid large vehicles
committees should be aware there is no
warning to pedestrians that coaches and
lorries will use the pavement
there are no warning signs
it looks like a pavement
acts like a pavement pedestrians are
reasonable in their assumption that it
actually is a pavement
so currently the easy access to the
garden enables pedestrians including
disabled parents with children in push
chairs to use this area to avoid
vehicles and potentially very serious
injury
if this is fenced off as proposed the
committee will have chosen to remove
this escape route
i don't commit his attention to the
healthy communities section of the core
strategy policy cs25 section 713
sdc wants to quote encourage better
facilities for cyclists and pedestrians
not i suggest to remove safe routes from
oncoming lorries
parking
we've heard and members read in the
report there are concerns over the
impact increased covers will have on
residents parking and i'm pleased that
the officer recognizes these concerns
the reference to the car park on cottage
lane as has been mentioned for possible
use
this is a private car park owned by the
shakespeare birthplace trust it's only
open from until 4 pm and the birthplace
trust is not aware of any approach from
the pub about this they have no plans to
open the car park in the evenings or
weekends
so this does not offer any solution to
the problems of parking
going to conservation the report states
that the site has planning history for
external structure within the garden
however as has been mentioned in may 21
the previous case officer reviewed the
original application with conservation
team they were not supportive and were
likely to recommend refusal
predominantly on heritage and visual
impact grounds
given the sensitivity of this
conservation area and the proximity to
great two listed buildings
is the committee absolutely convinced
that this large structure will be an
appropriate addition to the shotery
village conservation area
i imagine this committee may struggle to
find technical reasons to refuse this
application i've offered the policy cs25
but perhaps common sense and our duty of
care to residents
should be given due weight in this
instance
and i also propose a solution
were the traffic flow around shotery
reversed
this could mitigate the problem i have
raised this as a possibility with
highways
and until this can be considered i would
respectfully ask the committee to refuse
this application
thank you very much
thank you councillor curtis to have any
questions for our ward member councilor
mills thank you
council coach
what do you mean by reversed i'm sorry
i'm not with you on that if the traffic
fl so if you were coming
up hathaway lane
ins if the traffic flow around the whole
of shottery
were reversed
vehicles
wouldn't turn left as they currently do
so currently
vehicles coaches particularly going to
chattery school
have to turn left go all the way around
chattery and then down
in fact a number of vehicles coming up
hathaway lane
already turn right
against the directed flow of traffic
so you already have vehicles on a daily
basis i'm going to come in there yeah
that's great i mean i've tolerated it
for a second but it's completely it's
nothing to do with this it's a
completely hypothetical situation which
is not in front of us tonight so i'll
just leave that one if that's okay um
any other questions for the ward member
nope
in that case council curtis thank you
very much
right points for clarification council
jennings
hi amy
um i just want to be absolutely clear on
this
um
the railings um and the resin
all permitted developments so even if
we're to turn down this application
tomorrow they can start on that and put
them all up there
um
the only thing which we're dealing on
with is the pagoda
and the fixed seating
is that correct that is correct so and i
think within my officer report i refer
to the relevant parts so
um the railings as long as they are
no higher than one meter in height then
they are permitted development under
schedule two part two class a of the
town and country planning general
committed development order um and the
resin um surface um is permitted
development against um
schedule 2 part 7 class e
that's correct
council mills
thanks richard uh amy the
the ratings that are there already are
they being taken out
to make it a
great space i know it's not part of your
application
the rainings which are there already
yeah um is this curve here which is this
curve here which is to stay
this this day
okay
thank you
thank you chairman um
uh helen vins uh in her comments there
made reference to fixed seating needing
permission
my question is if these seats weren't
fixed
would they require permission
they wouldn't need permission no if they
weren't fixed it would be classed as de
minimis
okay
no points clarification the debate
anybody counselor jennings
right and i have a lot of sympathy um
for for the residents around there and
the roads and the highways issues
but the highways issues
it's nothing to do with us
here we're dealing we're talking it's
about the pagoda and fixed seating
the railings are permitted developments
so is the resin well they can start that
tomorrow they could have started it
yesterday
there's um they're allowed to do that
and there's no way you can stop it
um
they're doing these railings
0.6 meters inside of their boundary
which
they probably don't they don't have to
do that but they are doing that
um this is all about a pagoda
um and fixed seating
i understand the
what the pandemic has done to pubs
it's really important that we support
businesses in every way we can
i don't have a problem with pagodas
um
there's a conifer going
most people would like to see a lot of
conifers going
um
i don't have a problem with a pagoda or
a fixed seating i'm very happy to go
along with the officer's recommendation
that we approve this
granted is that a proposition that's a
proposition okay thank you
sorry councilman thank you very much mr
jim actually um
mr riley made a good point about
that so-called path um
i mean highways have said it's a runoff
but it it
but they do they they know it's a path i
mean it's it's it's odd isn't it i mean
the whole thing is to me is odd um
but
we're here to look at the raids as matt
said they they can put the ratings up
but
they are going to be set back
aren't they the railings by
what was it by amy
um it's approximately 0.6 meters
so if i i'll go to the plan
is that all right
thank you yeah
yeah yeah well um i can't say i'm i'm
too happy about this i think between the
rock and r plays on this mr chairman but
um
lots of concerns here i think
i think i'll chip in at this point
because no one else is indicated look
this is a prime example of heart versus
head isn't it i mean i can completely
see why everyone's concerned about it i
get it absolutely
and it'd be lovely if there was a an
easier
solution that maybe could be achieved
between uh the owners of the pub and
maybe local board member and members of
the community that'd be lovely if
somebody could find that
because i think i can't i can't sorry i
can't talk to anybody i think that is
something that's worth exploring even
beyond today's meeting
um because i think there could be a
solution there but it is not for this
committee to decide this
um
okay so i understand the problem but
it's not this committee that's that's
removing anything everything that's
being proposed that is bothering you
guys is to do with uh permitted
development so i have i'm
for this heavy heart but i'm going to
second council jennings proposal because
there's nothing else i see that we can
do
uh yes council hence seraphin john come
in thank you chair
um i'm concerned about what highways
said about this wasn't a path
well it seems to come around i'm looking
at google
earth at the moment
um
it starts as a path and then it's block
paving all the way around and then it
comes back to a path
so what the point obviously is for
vehicles to ride over that
now
safety is an issue
and
like people have said
if they're walking around there and a
vehicle comes then they've got to jump
onto that grass
yep that's that's good thanks i'm just
concerned about that okay miss jeff
johnny
clarify thank you for allowing me to to
jump in chair i just thought for members
benefit i might share with members the
um words that the highway authority uh
provided in their correspondence with
with the council
in further assessing the revisions
following reconsultation
they said this i must point out that the
footpath continually referred to is
actually an overrun constructed to a
suitable specification to specifically
allow large vehicles to negotiate the
corner whilst vehicles are parked on the
carriageway
the photographs submitted showing buses
crossing the area therefore demonstrate
that the overrun is being used for its
intended purpose it should also be noted
that the overrun is a current situation
that is in no way linked to the proposal
nor will the proposal worsen the
situation
therefore having taken a full assessment
of the development proposals the
response of warwickshire county council
on the local highway authority to the
above application remains one of no
objection
thank you
council dixon
thank you chairman um this may be our
last comment i'm not sure but
child safety i think the railings are
more likely to prevent a young child
toddler running out and into the path of
a vehicle and i think that is probably
more likely
than
a bus or a large vehicle actually
hitting a pedestrian who happens to be
on that corner walking around i don't
think vehicles
negotiate that corner quickly i think
any coach driver etc would see any
pedestrian who was occupying that space
and that pedestrian would be allowed to
get out of the way the idea that they
have to jump out and get onto that grass
and emergency i find difficult to
believe so i must admit if i was the
agent um my thanks my thoughts would be
i'd rather have the railings than not
have the railings
[Music]
right
we've gone around we've heard what we
think
i think we go to a vote it's been
proposed and second of the week grant
all those in favor please of grant
please show
one two three four five german those
against
one abstentions
that was against
hang on should we let's just run that
again please against
thank you okay all right
are there any extensions no then we
don't wait that's fine so therefore
apologies okay i think difficulty waving
cards around okay
so therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference 21 slash
zero zero six eight seven slash ful
there is no urgent business tonight
that's our last application in that case
i declare the meeting close thank you
very much everybody good evening
you